(upbeat music)
- Hollywood is simply one of
the coolest places in Cali.
It happens to be where
I was born and raised
and lived my whole life
in the 90046 area code.
There are so many reasons
to visit this area.
The iconic Hollywood sign
is certainly one of them,
but there is amazing food
and interesting
neighborhoods to walk around
and old Spanish Hollywood
architecture to marvel at.
By the way, could you
tell I'm from California?
I mean, I am stuck with this
accent for my whole life
and I couldn't be more proud.
If there's anything
more Cali about someone
than this kind of accent,
I'd like to meet them.
Drew's Cali is sponsored
by Visit California.
(upbeat music continues)